ashlee correct is the mother you just
saw in that video and she joins us
tonight from Philadelphia Ashley thanks
very much for coming on what you you
were there in the video with three girls
I think two of them are yours how old
are they so my daughters are 15 and 13
and my daughter's friend who is with us
is also 15 15 and 13 what did they think
of this it was it was a it was a
shocking experience I what what is not
seen in that video was our first
interaction with mr. Sims he approached
us about 20 minutes before that came in
I would say he came in hot he came in
yelling at us and really was yelling
very directly at the girls very
specifically at the girls so I moved
myself in between him and the girls
asked him you know please talk to me
let's let's have a conversation the two
of us as two adults but he continued to
yell at the girls and then eventually he
laughed and about 10 minutes later is
when he came back videotaping us so
after our first altercation with him I'd
you know Kent went and talked to my
girls and told them I'm you know I'm
really sorry this happened I'm really
proud of you guys for being here it was
Holy Thursday that this was something we
wanted to do too as a prayerful act of
service as we prepared for the Easter
Triduum which was going to begin that
night with Holy Thursday mass and I told
him I was you know it sometimes it's
hard to do the right thing but I was
really proud of them
sadly ironically the two older girls
looked at me and said mom that was
nothing compared to what people were
screaming at us at the March for Life in
January they went to the March for Life
with their high school so I guess I was
grateful that they had had some
experience before they were prepared for
it and because they were able to kind of
stay calm that helped my younger
daughter stay calm and you know we we
prayed for him then I said we'll
continue to pray for him and
just try to do the right thing and so
then he came back again videotaping us
it was we we weren't as shocked because
we just had an interaction with him
right about 10 minutes prior so yeah but
it was my adrenaline was up as a mom
my adrenaline was running well you know
I mean he seems to threaten you
he offers money for your identities yes
did you get it I was I was concerned for
my girls I you can see me speaking in
that video I was genuinely trying to
enter into just a dialogue with him to
try to bring the situation comment down
a little bit and and say to him on film
we're really here just praying for these
women and babies we're not looking for
an altercation I never come to clinics
looking for a fight it's always just
with peaceful prayerful intent and so
yes I was concerned that he said
multiple times that he wanted the
identities of my daughters we were at
that point already done we'd finished
our prayers we were leaving and so when
I realized he was not going to enter any
any kind of productive dialogue I
thought we'll just continue our exit and
we'll just leave what's wrong I never
thought yeah nothing I didn't ever think
Moore would really come of it so he
attacks you in that video and attacks
others in the video we showed before for
their skin color yeah what was that
about was there so where and what does
it mean I have no idea what it means you
would have to ask him we I mean my
daughters and I are Caucasian but we
were there to pray for all women
we certainly don't look at the color of
their skin as they come or go my
daughter's friend is not Caucasian
that's very evident and her her video
and in the pictures and she said several
times to him over the course of our
interactions I'm not white sir I know
it's in the video at least once so
fortunately we kind of got a laugh out
of that because what he was saying
literally just didn't make sense it
didn't like this and it's but it's it's
a racist attack it's bizarre has the
Democratic Party
of Pennsylvania or a Philadelphia
apologize to you or as near all said
I've not been contacted by anybody
yeah I know I haven't been contacted by
anyone in the Democratic Party about
this situation at all
he called you racist but as I understand
it you're arguing for fewer abortions
among african-american women he's
arguing for more but you're the race yes
yeah I mean you would have no it doesn't
make sense to me you'd have to ask mr.
Simms what his logic is behind that
because we try thanks Roy babies you
won't come on tonight but you were
gracious enough yeah to come and we're
glad that you did thanks very much thank
you